MALE SPEAKER: All right.
Thank you guys for coming
to this screening and Q&A
regarding "Extreme By Design."
It's a new documentary film
that premiered early December.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
December 11.
MALE SPEAKER: December
11, premiered on PBS.
So we're lucky
enough today to have
here Ralph King, the director,
along with two people that
are with him that are also
part of the Stanford D
School, the Stanford
Design School.
Which is one of the biggest
design thinking evangelists,
I would say.
I feel like you can't
hear about design thinking
without hearing about Stamford.
So it's great to
have them with us.
I'm going to tell you a
little bit about them,
and then we'll go
right to the screening.
And then have a Q&A
afterwards with an open forum
for everyone.
So "Extreme By
Design," at a time
of unprecedented
global challenges,
the under 30
millennial generation
has every reason
to be disengaged.
Yet plenty of
millennials are engaged.
Call it the empathy revolution.
That's a big Stanford thing.
"Extreme by Design," an
hour long documentary film,
brings this revolution to life
by following three Stanford
University students as they
design and build products
to meet basic needs
of the world's poor.
And I'll tell you
in just a minute,
expand on that, about a program
that our two other guests
have designed on PBS
Learning Media that's
an extension of this
experience and this lesson.
So I'll get to tell you
about that in a minute.
And our director,
Ralph, is a graduate
of Stanford, an
independent filmmaker,
and founder of
Hawk View Pictures.
Prior to filmmaking,
he spent 25 years
as a reporter for the
"Wall Street Journal"
and several national magazines.
And he was twice nominated by
"Wall Street Journal" editors
for the Pulitzer Prize and
won the National Association
of Science Writer's
Science in Society award
and the California
Governor's Media award.
Ralph recently
became a filmmaker.
And said you you've been
working on this one for about
four years?
RALPH KING: Yeah.
Right in the first four
years before it all started.
MALE SPEAKER: There you go.
So four years on
this one, I think
you would say this is
probably your first big one?
RALPH KING: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: Right?
So now onto our
two other guests.
One is Leticia Cavagnaro.
She comes from the
world of science,
where she acquired
a couple of degrees.
I like how you said that.
"A couple of
degrees," no big deal.
Strong analytical skills,
which she balances
with creative thinking,
and the ability to learn
from failed experiments.
Venturing outside
of the biology lab,
Leticia found that designing
learning experiences
was just as challenging
and even more rewarding.
Leticia is now adjunct faculty
at the School of Engineering's
Stanford Technology
Ventures Program
and the deputy
director-- there we go,
recently changed-- deputy
director of the National Center
for Engineering Pathways to
Innovation, known as Epicenter.
And as a co-lecturer on the
Creativity and Innovation
course, which here you
guys might know as CSI,
she gets to witness
the journey of students
as they develop their
creative confidence
and go on accomplishing
amazing things.
Which you guys will definitely
see in this next hour.
And our other guest
is Melissa Pelochino.
I love that last name.
That's such a good one.
Fellow at the Stanford D
school, her current focus
is on redesigning the
professional development
experience for K-12
teachers and administrators.
Which again, you'll see in
this PBS Learning Media.
Melissa is a former
teacher and administrator
in low-income schools.
And after learning about
design thinking in 2007,
she began her mission to
integrate the design thinking
process and mindsets into K-12
schools all over the world.
There's some really
interesting stories
that follow that as well.
Now to tell you about
the PBS Learning Media.
Would you probably call it
"Extreme by Design Watch
and Do"?
Did I get that right?
So the idea of this is it's
an interactive experience
on PBS Learning Media, which
is a resource for teachers.
And it's designed for fourth
through 12th grade students
to be completed after watching
the "Extreme by Design"
documentary.
For example, the first
episode, "Being an Innovator"
helps students think
and act like innovators
using the design
thinking approach.
Scenes from this documentary
are used to illustrate concepts,
and a protagonist acts as a
guide who provides instructions
and explanations
to the students.
And that's narrated
by all three?
Or one of the students
that we see in the film?
MELISSA PELOCHINO:
One of the students.
MALE SPEAKER: Just one of the
students we see in the film.
He narrates this whole learning
experience, which teachers then
take to their
classroom to expand
on this "Extreme
by Design" film.
Which I think is a very cool way
of not only learning something,
but then putting it into action.
So we'll go ahead and
watch the film now,
and then we'll have a
Q&A right afterwards.
AUDIENCE: How do you
come up with the universe
of potential solutions?
I didn't see anything on that.
What's the winnowing
process that you
go to take that large universe
down to a small subset
that you're then
going to proceed
to invest the time
and effort in.
And how can that be replicable?
Because I think
that's something that
would be useful
to take from this.
LETICIA BRITOS CAVAGNARO:
So I should say,
I do not teach this
specific class.
And there's some variability
amongst the different D School
classes.
But for sure that the
process is not proprietary,
and it's all shared.
Many of the resources
that we use for teaching
are shared on the web.
Mostly, in a nutshell, the
design thinking process
would start with
identifying problems
from the user perspective.
I think that came
through in the film.
So for coming up
with ideas, there's
many techniques
that you can use.
But mostly it's a
very simple concept
of going beyond the
first right answer.
Right?
And I think that when we
teach mostly engineers
or other technical
students, we give them
a very, very
well-defined problem.
And we teach them to
come up with a solution.
We should push them to think
of many possible solutions.
So just that simple
concept is the start
of getting them to think
beyond the first right answer.
Do you want to add?
MELISSA PELOCHINO:
I would just add
in terms of criteria for
selection, it ranges.
Sometimes criteria for selection
is given by the instructors,
and sometimes it's not.
I would say most importantly,
it's what's feasible.
If you're having to
actually create something
that you can make,
either an experience
or a product, and also
what meets the need
that you identified earlier on
in the process in the best way.
And so students do brainstorm.
There were some short
clips in the movie.
They said "trainstorming"
as sort of a play
on brainstorming.
And some other short parts
where they were throwing
Post-its up with a whole
bunch of different ideas.
But as Leticia
said, there's a lot
of different
strategies for getting
outside the box of
what's possible,
and to really weld ideas.
And then criteria for narrowing
that down and selecting it.
And there's several.
RALPH KING: I guess I would
just add to that, defining
the problem, as I
guess we all know
is much more important
than finding the solution.
So the Indonesian group that
was on this quixotic adventure
that they didn't
realize they were
looking for the wrong
thing, initially.
The partner in those
countries, NGOs,
will give you an assignment.
But often you end
up way over here
in the process of figuring
out something you can solve,
or something that's the right
size for a six month course,
or the little blue
sleeping bag, the embrace.
Their initial assignment
was to come up
with a cheaper,
in-hospital incubator.
And within a matter of
days, when they were out
in the field, they realized
that 95% of the babies
are born out in the rural
villages and no electricity.
So they basically walked
away from that partner
and came up with that design.
So problem definition,
I think, is also
a long and important process.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks again.
I was curious about,
it occurred to me
that the local people
in Indonesia or wherever
would be motivated to
help solve these problems.
And maybe they had
no time or resources,
but there must be bright
people there, too.
Is there effort
to, I don't know,
transition some of the
solutions that way?
Instead of, say, to Walmart
or wherever, and help
continue the projects?
RALPH KING: Yeah.
I mean there's no--
this movie is set up
as a West to East
kind of solution--
but there's no reason why it
shouldn't be the other way.
Or West to West and East
to East kind of thing.
That the problem
solvers should ideally
come from the culture
in which they live.
Stanford, for one,
has an organization
called The Seed Institute.
They got a big gift from a local
couple that is now setting up
D School like innovation labs
in places like Ghana and Myanmar
and I think eight
other countries,
they plan to create
for local entrepreneurs
to learn the methodologies and
to incubate their companies.
And then sometimes the
partners in these countries
will come back to Stanford and
bring their staffs with them.
Like the group, you saw the red
treadle pump there in Myanmar?
Well that organization,
Proximity Design,
sent a big group
back with our teams
to study the school
and the process.
And then have now
carried that back there.
So there's an objection
raised that this
seems a little
neo-colonial and just
another version of charity.
But there's no
reason why it can't
be something that
operates locally.
In fact, one of the projects
was, if you saw on the map,
set in Arizona, an
Apache reservation.
So within American
culture, obviously, there's
lots of room for these
kinds of projects.
And they happen here.
But this particular class
tends to go overseas
because of the way it's set up.
MELISSA PELOCHINO:
And in fact this film
is serving as inspiration
for exactly that to happen.
We're working with a school in
India of fourth and fifth grade
students who saw the film.
And Ralph was there through
Skype to answer some Q&A.
And then Leticia and I are
going to be leading them
through their own
design challenge
later next week, actually.
So the film is
serving as inspiration
to empower people,
children all over the world
to solve their own problems.
AUDIENCE: So, Ralph, how did you
decide how to tell this story?
Did you just follow your three
groups around with a camera,
or did you look at
some other groups,
and already have an outline
of what you were looking for?
RALPH KING: The
question is why I
decided to do this
particular story.
I was working at the
Stanford Business School
when I heard about this class.
And I spent a year auditing the
course, or a six month cycle.
And so I, as part
of that, went out
with one of the student teams,
I mentioned earlier, to Myanmar.
And filmmakers and journalists
weren't welcome in Myanmar
at that time, so
I was a "student."
And it was day four
of the trip, and I
was feeling very
discouraged because I
hadn't had any
startling observations
to contribute to my team.
And so I was kind of
shuffling through the town.
And I noticed a family sitting
in a pagoda in a meditation
room.
They had come in for the
bizarre, the county fair, that
was happening in the town,
and were about to leave.
I sat down and asked if
I could interview them.
They said sure.
I started firing all my
journalistic questions at them
and madly scribbling
my notebook.
About 15 minutes into this
interview, I looked up.
And there, in addition
to the six people,
35 other people had just glided
in silently and sat down.
And were watching
this whole thing
going on with this
crazy westerner.
And in that moment, I
just put my book down.
And I leaned back.
And I just was
filled with ecstasy.
I've really felt
for the first time
in 25 years as a journalist
that I understood
the difference between
gathering facts and observing
with an open heart.
And this sudden
appearance of people
totally unbeknownst to
me was like, for me,
this kind of trumpets
blaring from the heavens,
how much experience
I tend to exclude.
It just was like discovering
a new capacity in myself.
And so for the next two days,
I was like walking on air.
And I thought, well, if even
auditing this class is having
this kind of effect
on me, imagine
what it's doing for
these 20 somethings who
have skin in the game
and actually have
to produce something for
people that they meet.
So I felt like there was
a powerful element to it.
And it was kind of like Pam
said, where the boundaries just
collapse.
And in that moment, she felt
like she just had to do this.
Well that's kind of the way
I felt about this story.
And so I guess
that's why I did it.
And I guess I would also like
to say that now that the film is
made, it's become
something else.
And that's partly why Melissa
and Leticia are here today.
Because there is a kind
of movement in education
now to bring design
thinking and these methods
more into the mainstream,
more into young people's
lives, in schools, and
also into companies.
I know here at Google,
it's a fairly common
or fairly well-known thing.
But in other parts of
the country, less so.
But we see little beginnings.
So after making the film, I
came to my friends and said,
how do we get this in
front of young people?
Young people don't watch PBS.
Which is where it broadcasted.
So we start talking
about a workshop.
And how could we incorporate
the film in a workshop?
And so we did little clips.
And we had this 90
minute workshop.
And that was great.
But we did it in some schools,
but how do we scale it?
So then PBS offered
us an opportunity
to put on their teacher
portal something online.
And so Melissa and Leticia,
God bless them, took the film
and created this wonderful
hour-long exercise,
like a press play
exercise, that takes
young people in a classroom
through the basic elements,
the steps, of design thinking.
So it gives them a flavor and
a taste of what it's like.
And so what keeps
me up at night now
is figuring out ways like
this to scale design thinking
education.
We're at a moment in
our education system
where the common
core is coming in,
which is much more process
oriented rather than content
oriented.
So it's kind of an inflection
point that is timely.
And I actually would welcome
any ideas that you have,
if you've experienced
the scaling
of a new kind of
concept here at Google.
And how that's done.
I'm really looking and searching
for answers to that right now.
AUDIENCE: I would love to
know about the challenges
that you guys had trying to get
something like the CSI process
onto this online
workshop for students.
Because here it's a few hours
of hands-on, in the classroom,
stuff that we do.
So how did you guys
get that into scale
and what were the challenges?
LETICIA BRITOS
CAVAGNARO: So I should
say that before attempting
to do this module for k-12,
I had approached Ralph,
having seen the movie.
And I did a massive online
course on design thinking.
And I selected some of
the clips to illustrate
some of the challenges.
So I do believe that
you can translate
this type of
experiential learning
into an online experience.
You just have to not be literal.
Right?
So when we think about an
online resource, we think, OK.
There's going to be a video
of a lecture, and then a quiz
that basically quizzes
you on whether you were
paying attention to the lecture.
Right?
But the way I
defined that course
was completely different.
I thought, how can
I design something
that is very personal
for each learner?
And use the metaphor of
kind of like a "Choose
Your Own Adventure" book.
Right?
So you would, according
to what you were seeing
and what you were answering, and
like no right answer quizzes.
You would be pointed
to different parts
of the materials that
were meaningful to you.
Right?
So when we approach doing this
module, one of the challenges,
I would say, is that you
want to present the learner
with a meaningful challenge.
But it's something that they
can see the human aspect of it.
So one of the things that
we struggled really with
was defining the right to
challenge to give the students.
And not something that was
directly coming from the movie,
so they already saw what the
student's solution had been.
And they would gravitate
towards doing something similar.
Right?
So we took a challenge of
one of the teams that was not
portrayed in the movie, was
just mentioned at the beginning,
as one of the main challenges.
Do you want to?
MELISSA PELOCHINO: Yeah.
I would say that was
definitely a challenge.
Another challenge we
had is sort of providing
an experiential learning
opportunity for students.
Being mindful that teachers
need to manage their class
and that this may not be the
type of learning and teaching
that a teacher might
feel comfortable with.
So trying to find the right
balance between the giving
or delivering of
material and content,
and the experience
that the students
would be having, I think
was definitely challenging.
We're in a time right
now where teachers
were taught in a way that's
very different than we're now
asking them to teach.
And so being mindful of
that gap and sort of finding
the right balance there
was very challenging.
And how we sort of answered
that for ourselves was providing
a lot of scaffolding
for the students.
So, for example, we ask them
to identify a bunch of needs
that a particular "character"
that we present might have.
But then we present
an actual need
that we want the whole group
to solve for all together.
So we gave them the
freedom to sort of generate
their own ideas.
But then we kept it
sort of whole class
as they move
through the process.
Which enabled the
teacher, we felt,
to manage a little bit easier.
LETICIA BRITOS
CAVAGNARO: In a way,
the resource needs
to be a learning
experience for the students,
but also for the teacher.
Right?
Because we wanted if
this is going to scale,
this is going into the hands
of a teacher who is not
knowledgeable about
the same thinking.
So they might not be comfortable
with being the facilitator.
So what we did was we
took one of this students,
Darrell, that
appears in the movie,
is one of the water
storage team students.
And he was the facilitator.
So this particular module, or
one instance of the module,
was, just as Ralph said,
just like press play and go.
So you would have the
teacher on the screen saying,
and now we're going to do this.
And the teacher would be
kind of like the facilitator
on the side, providing
the materials.
And in a way, giving the
teacher the opportunity to
observe the students in action.
And seeing the interaction with
this in-screen facilitator.
Right?
And this is an experiment.
We really don't know, and
we're eager to find out,
how this works in schools.
And hopefully we'll be able
to go into some classrooms
and see how it works.
RALPH KING: Leticia is modest.
Her MOOC that she
created at Stanford
attracted thousands
and thousands
of students who
actually completed it,
which also with MOOC
is not that common.
And had some really
amazing feedback
and experiences from it.
And so the scaling
of design thinking
is happening in
a number of ways.
And these folks are
among the pioneers of it.
AUDIENCE: So in the
movie, in the class,
I didn't see many
design students
with the design backgrounds.
So I saw the professors who
are from technology backgrounds
or from psychology background,
so I wonder how much effort
made by design
professors or students
with the design background?
And how many people
have design backgrounds
get involved into this process?
RALPH KING: Usually in that
course, there are a quarter,
or maybe not quite that
many, of the students
are from the design.
There's a design program,
a joint program in design,
at the graduate
level at Stanford.
But it's part of the Mechanical
Engineering Department,
I think.
So there's a lot of dialogue
between the design department
and the D School, which is
not a department itself.
It's just where people come
together to intermingle.
And so I'd say anywhere from
10 to 25% of the students
had a design or were
currently in a design program.
But they had, all around
them, these instructors
who were very immersed
in the design process.
But as we said at
the very beginning,
very few had ever made
anything in their lives.
Or designed anything.
So I think the idea is
creating this attitude,
that if I see a problem in
the world, I can fix it.
Kind of forget the
whole idea of design.
It's a kind of optimism.
And I can figure
out how to find out,
how to get the answer
to this problem,
if I care enough about it.
LETICIA BRITOS CAVAGNARO:
I would say that students
with a design background, for
the purpose of the D School
are just one more
discipline that
contributes to a
multidisciplinary team.
But we really think
design thinking
is a much broader language for
creating a problem definition
and solving.
And we are all designers
in a way, right?
And getting that
attitude, as Ralph
said, into every discipline.
AUDIENCE: I would totally agree,
design thinking and design are
basically different things.
But I wonder, for the
students in this class,
this Extreme class, did they
get any design skill training?
Because during
the whole process,
they need to do the
research, do the interviews,
so there are a lot of
design skills or research
skills involved in the process.
So I wonder, except
the design thinking,
did they get any other
training or specific skills?
MELISSA PELOCHINO: Each
class has its own sort
of ways that they convey
the design thinking
process and methodology.
So I can't-- I mean, you could
probably speak better than us
because we don't teach
that particular class--
but I can say in the class
that we're teaching right now
at the D School, we do teach the
skills required for the design
thinking process alongside the
mindsets and sort of attitudes
as well.
In a way that's
very experiential.
And then they go out into the
field and they apply them.
So there definitely is
training along the way,
throughout any design
thinking course.
And I would also add that
the D School is not actually
a school.
By design, it doesn't
issue degrees on purpose.
They didn't want to have a
space that like the creatives
are over here and everybody
else is over here.
It's specifically a
place where people
from all different disciplines
and backgrounds come together.
And sort of one of the
cornerstones of design thinking
is that interdisciplinary
cross-breeding
of ideas and perspectives.
That that's what yields the
most creative and innovative
results.
LETICIA BRITOS CAVAGNARO:
And I would, building on
that, it's a place
where people come
for different amounts
of time and involvement.
Right?
So it's not like you have
a set amount of classes
that you have to complete
to be a D School graduate.
You do not get that.
But students can come and take
a class and get a sense of that.
And then go back to
their disciplines
and apply some of that.
Or they can become kind of like
D School junkies, I would say,
and come and take eight,
nine classes, to the point
that that becomes like a really
great part of what they do.
And what they will
do in the future.
RALPH KING: And these two,
together with Frederick,
are teaching a class in
creativity right now.
And for 40 spots, you
had, what, 150 applicants?
LETICIA BRITOS
CAVAGNARO: About 100.
We had to actually teach
the class twice this year,
because last year, we had
200 applicants for 40 spots.
So that's why we are
now teaching it twice.
RALPH KING: So the
demand is just far
outstripping the supply of
this sort of thing, right now.
LETICIA BRITOS
CAVAGNARO: And it's
a class that actually
is not required.
And in some cases, it competes
with their requirements.
So some students are
trying to struggling, like,
oh, I want to take this class.
But I have to take
units for my degree.
And so what do I do?
Right?
So it's a great testament of
this revolution of the students
feel this need to acquire these
sets of skills and mindsets
to be creative problem solvers.
And we're trying
to find more ways
to spread that across
Stanford in different ways.
Not just with the
standalone classes, but
how can we embed
that in every class
in the fabric of Stanford?
AUDIENCE: So over the
weekend, I had the fortune
of being at D School, attending
the Bootleg Boot camp.
And I wanted to
totally appreciate
the school, and
the great material.
And not just the material,
but the peer leaders.
I really learned a lot.
And I totally appreciate that.
And just like Ralph said, I
felt like I was walking on air.
There was just so much
energy, so much creativity.
So thanks.
And keep up the great work.
LETICIA BRITOS CAVAGNARO:
Thank you for coming.
And you probably met one
of our course assistants
was one of the D
leaders, Ben Baldwin.
These are students
who are now learning
to teach design thinking.
So we call an open call for
people to come to D School
and go through a basic training.
And the students are teaching.
So thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: I think that
was actually the perfect way
to finish.
So thank you guys so much.
We really appreciate
you coming out.